lawyers are increasingly predicting that
failed former president donald trump is
inevitably going to be indicted and
we're going to look at one of those
op-eds momentarily now there are many
people asking if trump is indicted
is he going to be arrested and
perp-walked and booked at a federal
prison the way that
many so-called normal people are
and i believe the answer is obviously
not and we're going to get back to that
in a moment but let's first start with
the case that is increasingly being made
very interesting article in the daily
beast by brad moss who says it's over
trump will be indicted the case is as
follows uh brad moss says
donald trump will be indicted by a
federal grand jury and he believes that
the reason for that is as follows
number one trump was in unauthorized
possession of national defense
information namely properly marked
classified documents number two trump
was put on notice by the u.s government
that he was not permitted to retain
those documents at mar-a-lago
and number three
trump continued to maintain possession
of the documents and allegedly undertook
efforts to conceal them in different
places throughout the property up until
the fbi finally executed a search
warrant earlier this month and moss says
this is the ball game folks absent some
unforeseen change in factual or legal
circumstances
he believes there is little left for the
justice department to do
but to decide do you indict before the
midterms or after the midterms in terms
of what you ask for the grand jury and
as moss also points out the cruelest
irony for trump is it never needed to be
this way and that's a theme with donald
trump much of the uh problems that
donald trump uh gets into
many of the problems are a result of
trump's own doing and self-inflicted
harm so let's now think this through if
trump is indicted will he be arrested
book perp
walked at a federal prison the answer is
almost certainly not uh donald trump
will almost certainly be given the
opportunity to present himself
to the fbi on his own terms
and uh it's all going to be handled in a
very different way than it is with
so-called mere mortals and i use that
term extraordinarily sarcastically now
there is a counterpoint to that
which is when you look at what trump is
being investigated for based on all of
the documents that we now have
um
when you're talking about espionage act
violations
you often don't give those people a
chance to turn themselves in you arrest
them and that's an absolutely perfectly
natural analysis
but it's trump it's trump and we have to
set our expectations correctly the fbi
and secret service would almost
certainly just coordinate the delivery
of trump to the justice department uh
trump will probably be not by the way i
i
you know if in let's not get ahead of
ourselves if and when this happens it's
going to be a historic and historic
moment it's gonna be both in american
history unquestionably and they will say
it's unprecedented and that means it's
wrong well no trump did things no
president did so now the outcomes are
also different than they were with any
other president but
donald trump is almost certainly going
to fundraise off of this if donald trump
is indicted and he's given some bail
amount
he is going to fundraise off of it it's
going to be absolutely incredible to see
donald trump doing this so i think if we
want to be as realistic as possible i
would put out of your minds that you're
going to see trump in an orange jumpsuit
behind bars
i would bet anything i have that that's
not going to happen i'm with you
that trump and the people around him who
were complicit in what are now
countless instances of wrongdoing
they deserve to be prosecuted and found
found guilty in prison there's no doubt
about it but even just think about it i
mean trump in a federal prison like even
if it was even if it was plausible that
trump would be sentenced
it is a national security risk to have a
former president in a federal prison
it's an insane conversation that we're
even having but if i think ahead five
six seven eight steps
and i think about if there are charges
and if there's a conviction or a plea
deal that involves some kind of uh
serious consequence
it's trump restricted to one of his
luxury clubs right i mean i think we
would all probably agree that's the
direction it goes but the big headline
is not that that's speculative that's
about the future the big headline is
lawyers increasingly believe trump is
going to be indicted and the growing
question is what exactly is donald
trump's legal defense going to be and
that's what i want to talk about next